welcome to the dtps seminar everyone it
is an honor to your host Paul S Burger
who is currently a professor at the
Department of Mathematics of University
of California Santa Barbara all right
thank you I'd like to thank the
organizers for this opportunity to talk
today I thought I would share a little
bit of work that we've been doing on
leveraging recent developments in
generative modeling in particular
machine learning approaches that have
been emerging especially in the Deep
Learning Community for the purposes of
developing multi-scale models reductions
and other types of representations for
non-linear dynamical systems of larger
scientific simulations you know so fluid
mechanics materials modeling and so on
so I'm going to talk about a rather sort
of small piece of the work that we're
doing and this is relatively recent work
and I'd be very happy to continue
discussions offline about various
directions and applications so just to
set a little bit the context in which
I'm motivated in developing these
data-driven methods is what we're really
after are ways that we can utilize
observations either taken from
experiment or higher Fidelity
computation simulations and really use
data-driven perspectives to essentially
learn representations which we can use
as a simulator either to predict future
behaviors of the system or in the
context of a much larger calculation
where perhaps the part of the model that
we're interested in replacing is very
computationally expensive to compute at
a high level of detail but for the
purposes of larger scale phenomena that
we're interested in a much sort of
coarsened or simplified model would
potentially do the trick but it might be
very difficult to arrive at that through
kind of traditional asymptotic
techniques and so what I'm also
interested in is in doing this in the
context not only of deterministic
systems but stochastic systems and
that's primarily what I'll talk about
today I feel like again to build some
context I need to say a little bit about
techniques that are out there and have
been successfully applied for this type
of problem so they can kind of compare a
little bit and contrast some of the
objectives of the techniques that were
developed and so there's been a lot of
work done over the years of course the
data-driven modeling of Dynamics
probably one of the most notable one is
this proper orthogonal decomposition
this is essentially a form of a
principal component analysis where the
basic strategy to build up your
dynamical model
um here I'm just showing a fluid
mechanics model on the upper right would
be to look at the modes in the system
essentially that vary the most so
essentially you would take your flow
field create this very high dimensional
Point cloud and effectively you're doing
principal component on that a really
nice development in the direction of
incorporating Dynamics within this kind
of linear Frameworks is the dynamic mode
decomposition introduced by Schmid in
2010 and lots of developments by by
various groups and communities including
abronto and Kutz in various directions
and again this is a linear based model
again that's there's a lot of advantages
having lender-based models they're
they're much more straightforward to
build theory for and you know
potentially computationally efficient
then more efficient than training let's
say deep in our networks and so the
basic idea in things like Dynamic mode
decomposition is you're basically going
to take dynamical information into
account by saying well which modes are
sort of most indicative of that
prediction of what's going to happen in
the future over some set of snapshots so
you're basically you looking for again
the sort of best linear model and kind
of the best basis in order to try to
align your your linear predictor with
the underlying data observations there's
also been really nice work done on using
symbolic approaches essentially uh L1
regression things like the lasso
combined with these symbolic
dictionaries and that's a way that you
can overcome some of the issues that I
mentioned of these previous linner
models and again lots of successes and
nice applications of these techniques uh
and but you know this has the drawback
that you do need a sufficiently
expressive Library so that you kind of
have coverage over the space of
potential Dynamic representations that
are relevant for your system so my main
point in mentioning these approaches I
just want to give kind of some context
of what's out there and it kind of just
helps set a little bit the the
overarching environment in which we're
trying to develop these data-driven
techniques I'm also going to incorporate
noise so it'll also be a generative
component that I'll be talking about in
detail and so the objective is try to
not just recapitate the behavior that
you're seeing in the training set but
really learns for intrinsic model so
that you can make either longer term
predictions or ideally in the context of
a lot of these scientific Computing
applications be able to replace one of
your more expensive models with one
that's much cheaper but a long time
simulator and so that poses a lot of
challenges from the data-driven modeling
perspective because you know depending
on how you go about this your model
class might not have certain intrinsic
properties that we're used to and we
design into our numerical methods you
know such as things like stability which
obviously be very important for a long
time prediction also another challenge
is incorporating prior knowledge to the
extent that we can we often know a lot
about you know the physics of the system
or other mathematical structure in the
system and so we'd also like ways of
including that as inductive biases in
our data driven methods so I'll talk a
little bit about where I think their
opportunities do that as well in some of
these nonlinear approximation approaches
as I said these developments in the
neural networks community in particular
generative models and I'll kind of put
it in a little bit larger probabilistic
context and then there's a lot of
interesting uh directions I think that
this could be pursued uh for for a lot
of the applications that I showed on the
previous slides but going Beyond again
the sort of linear approximations to to
then incorporate various types of
non-linear approximation classes
um so it's two motivating examples and
I'll come back and I'll give some
results for these one of which is you
know basically systems identification or
extracting State information which is
important in many different problems
including things like control
and the objective here basically is to
learn key parameters from observations
of the Dynamics these things go by you
know many different names depending on
the community uh and now what we're
trying to utilize here as I showed in
the upper right just a little animation
if I'm trying to learn for example in
this Ornstein Woolen back process uh you
can think of it intuitively from the
mechanics point of view as a bead spring
system where I'm trying to learn
simultaneously the stiffness the damping
and the temperature of the system
um you know what we want to do is
somehow probe the Dynamics in a way that
would be indicative of those different
properties so there's going to be an
interesting challenge whenever you're
trying to estimate a model from the
Dynamics that you may you have to be
careful basically that you're probing
the Dynamics on the appropriate time
skills and that you have sufficient
coverage over the response range that
would be sensitive to those particular
parameters but the overall objective
here is to try to learn dynamical
representations from observations sample
trajectories also in reductions and
course grading I'll show an example
where um you know we're trying to learn
essentially unknown Force laws and so
how that can be done again for this
General perspective in this case um this
would be a non-parametric estimation
problem where we want to learn an
unknown Force law for example uh in
something like longevon Dynamics and so
problems analogous to this come up in a
lot of different contexts in developing
again reductions so that you can
simulate things on larger time scales to
overcome for example sources of
stiffness or in coarse grain modeling of
course which is very popular for example
in the Material Sciences community so
some of the interesting things that you
could potentially do if you had good
non-linear estimation methods is you
know not have to hand craft your
estimators for things like the the force
law so one of the common ways you might
try to go about doing this is to use
something like maximum likelihood
estimation but of course the immediate
challenge you run into in the setting of
these Dynamic representations is
uh that you have to specify likelihood
functions you have to compute those
potentially on very high dimensional
probability spaces and so I'm going to
show some Alternatives uh to that
approach all right so I just wanted to
give some of the kind of key key
motivations here in context of um where
we're trying to develop uh these
techniques just to give a a sort of
overview of some of the issues that
arise and I think there's a lot of
potentially interesting ways again to
leverage a lot of the recent
developments in the machine Learning
Community
um in the case of stochastic Dynamics in
some sense we're trying to learn an
entire ensemble and so there'll be some
interesting issues that arise there
given the roles that noise plays in
stochastic phenomena and then of course
as I said before we'd like to do all
this to obtain robust uh representations
that are stable for the purposes of
either a long time prediction or or
simulation all right so I think I've
said a you know enough at this sort of
the high level and I'll start getting
into some of the more uh details of the
techniques that we're going to leverage
and to further develop um so if you're
not familiar with General adversarial
networks I'm just going to go through
really quick
um what these techniques are these are
recent developments in the machine
Learning Community closely related to
generative modeling statistics um and so
what I'm going to do is just go through
perspective on gendered adversarial
networks this is basically a way for us
to train a simulator or an implicit
generative model that is uh this
function that I'm showing here which is
G of Z and G of Z basically has some
noise source and what it's going to do
is generate a sort of collection of
samples and the objective here is to
take our training data and take our
implicit generator and have some way of
comparing the samples that we get from
the
um the the training set with the samples
that were produced uh by the generator
now as I mentioned before you know one
way that this has traditionally be done
if you know a lot analytically about the
generators you could use things like
maximum likelihood estimation but if you
do that right this requires a
specification of likelihood functions
requires you to go and and perform those
calculations during the training Loop
which could potentially be quite quite
challenging the appeal of doing this
adversarial training approach is instead
of relying on a sort of pre-specified
likelihood function what we're going to
do is simultaneously train another model
this could potentially well be a neural
network but can be taken from any model
class you like and I'll show a little
bit about that in a minute and basically
the job of this discriminator uh is to
characterize how closely the samples
that were produced by the generator
differ and so the discriminator you can
think of as playing a role analogous to
a classifier and if I have this
collection of samples its job is to say
well did those samples come from the
training set or the generator if it can
distinguish that readily then your you
know your generator uh needs to be
improved you could think of this as kind
of like a two-player game where if I had
a classifier loss for example the
discriminators would be aiming to
minimize the loss while the generator
would be aiming to maximize that loss
for the discriminative and so by making
different choices of the discriminator
we can actually realize uh different
divergences and metrics for comparing
the empirical measures of the samples of
generator with uh with that of the the
training data distribution all right so
that's a quick overview of Afghans so
you have a generator G what's different
from some of the other modeling
approaches is we're not actually going
to write down ever the probability
distribution or measure directly we're
simply going to have an algorithm that
generates from some random input samples
and then we're going to tune essentially
that algorithm so that it produces high
quality samples that agree with the
training set and then discriminator the
simplest case would be a binary
classifier which I'll use for
illustration and then I'll I'll show how
we can extend that for the purposes of
these uh learning of Dynamics if it were
binary classifier basically the idea
would be it would give us a number maybe
between 0 and 1 telling us the
probability that it thinks it was
produced by the data distribution versus
produced by the the implicit generator
so I'm going to write these probability
densities down for the purposes of
having a theoretical perspective but in
practice you're only going to be working
with samples from G and D will only be
operating on Sample sets from from G and
the and the training except
uh so basically you can think about a
little bit like it's like a little game
where G is kind of acting like a
counterfeiter d is kind of a classifier
seeing whether this is real or fake and
your job is to create such good samples
again that the discriminator uh can't
can't tell all right and we'll we'll see
what that how that plays out um
mathematically
um in in a little bit and uh and that'll
inform our choices for uh the
discriminator model classes all right so
the way that we're gonna typically
um play this game is what we'll do is
we'll have a synthetic data set which is
a mixture of samples that are taken from
the generator samples that are taken
from the um from the training set and
those get mixed together and we put
label one on everything from the
training set and we put label zero on
everything from the implicit generator
and now in leverage results from the
classification Theory to create a loss
function for the discriminator model uh
D and so the score of the discriminator
is basically going to be you know the
zero one loss for assigning the correct
labels uh to those sample points now if
we look at it from you know point of
view of let's say the Bayesian
classifier you can see that if D of X is
interpreted as a probability the ideal
way to try to classify would be for D to
estimate the probability that the label
is one given that sample point because
you know you could have that both the
generator and the data distribution
produce the exact same sample of course
in practice there'll be a little bit of
smoothness that needs to come into the
problem uh you know where you want this
for X's that are close that they have
the appropriate probability assigned
um and then one minus D is basically the
probability that the label y was
assigned so of course the base
classifier would be to just take the ARG
Max of that conditional uh probability
what we're basically trying to do is
develop an algorithm to find effectively
that Bayesian classifier for this mixed
uh synthetic data set which which is
acting in for the classifier's point of
view is effectively like a training set
but I call it synthetic uh training or
synthetic label data just to not just to
distinguish the original data from this
synthetic one that we're using for the
purposes of the yans and so if we mix
together one half probability the things
from the generator and one half
probability from the um the original
training data this would be the
distribution that we're training the
discriminator over and the base
classifier actually can be worked out
analytically to be this so it'll
essentially just be the probability of
the data distribution generating that
sample over the sum of the probabilities
of the data model distributions having
generated that probability
so you can see that the optimal if we
were to actually perform all of our
optimization perfectly the best
discriminator the one that would
minimize the the loss the zero one loss
would be given by this analytic
expression here of course in practice we
don't get that but some interesting
outcomes you see is that if I had that
the data distribution the model
distribution lined up perfectly I would
have that this D of X is one half and
that kind of means that the
discriminator was maximally confused
didn't know whether it should assign a
label of zero or or one is the way you
can intuitively interpret that so if you
now go and you you get a little more
mathematical about what we're actually
Computing here we have the subjective
function uh the Theta D here are the
parameters for the model class of the
discriminator and the Theta G here are
the parameters of the model class of the
generator what we're basically
minimizing in the loss function is this
expectation of the log label probability
here this is that the usual zero one
loss this is what that amounts to and
now if you break it down for what we
have for the synthetic set data set
you'll see that it breaks into these two
parts and this is the typical loss that
would be used for discriminator in
something like against now we're going
to see there's some drawbacks to this
and I'm going to have to reformulate the
Gans for the purposes of learning these
stochastic systems but I wanted to kind
of show you the sort of standard uh and
original formulation before I uh do
those modifications so at the end of the
day what you'd be doing is trying to
find an ARG Min of this subjective
function to get your discriminator
basically you're trying to have the best
classifier possible given that synthetic
data set and then the generator's job is
basically to try to mess up the
discriminator's ability to achieve a low
loss in other words make your samples so
good looking that the discriminator
really can't tell between the samples
it's producing and those of the data
distribution so that's sort of the
underlying strategy and this is how it
plays out mathematically I've used a
little bit of a modified objective here
just to avoid some issues with Vanishing
gradients but nonetheless that's what
this objective is ultimately achieving
when you ARG Max it with respect to the
the generator's parameters you know very
prone to oscillations if you use kind of
this alternative descent asset but
anyway I just want to mention what the
typical training objective is and we're
going to use some analytic techniques to
work around that issue of oscillations
that arises I'll just show an example
with learning something which is
relatively simple which is a gaussian
but the key point I really want to make
here is you don't know an advanced tip
typically what is a good noise source
and so the real sort of issue here is
the noise Source I took to be a uniform
distribution I want to compute something
like a gaussian you'll see that even
trying to train as on a Model that's
this simple Gans runs into some and you
see immediately that you get a lot of
oscillations during training and really
what's going on here is it's very
difficult often in Gans to to resolve
the tails especially if you don't have a
decaying Nori Source but you know you
could replace this obviously with a
gaussian noise source and you'd very
readily be able to learn the model but
this is really the scenario that you
often encounter in practice is the noise
Source often needs to undergo some
pretty radical transformations in order
to realize the target uh probability
distribution so we want to be very
careful about the the objectives that
we're using to train the Gans and
there's this issue of oscillations if we
use simply this relaxation this gradient
descent for discriminator granite asset
for for the generators and so what we've
done is introduced a way to modify the
standard formulation of Gans to
incorporate some additional features to
deal with some of those issues related
to oscillations to deal with some of the
issues related to to the noise that I
mentioned as well as the the high
dimensionality and so refer to this as
stochastic Dynamic Gans so the basic
objective again is to learn a implicit
generator and generative model G of Z
here x would now be the trajectories
that we'd like to be again a sample
based so we'll use this setup with
discriminators now if You observe
stochastic trajectories the reason why I
can't just use the standard Gans
formulation is the dynamic trajectories
would be very very high dimensional
random variables and so you can imagine
it being very prone to not having good
sample coverage in fact if you do the
standard against formulation that I
showed before you can show that that
loss that you ultimately get is based on
callback libler Divergence you have to
be very careful about probability
distributions being absolutely
continuous with respect to the other and
so as a consequence getting coverage in
the sample space would be quite
challenging when you go to very high
dimensions and so what we're going to do
is we're going to use the probabilistic
structure that we often know in advance
about dynamical systems for example uh
you know if we're looking at something
like longify Dynamics we know that the
the new state is likely to depend on
some previous number of states in that
case uh two states and so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to develop my
learning methods over the class of
General m-step stochastic integrators
and that's going to be the model class
essentially for my implicit generators
and by doing that I can sort of build in
various inductive biases including
learning within let's say the framework
of numerical methods which are known to
be stable at least for sufficiently
small time steps and and basically from
that I can then learn my representations
in a way where I have a viable candidate
simulator in hand so from the modeling
point of view or probabilistic point of
view you can think about us learning
over essentially probabilistic graphical
models where we're going to allow for
State K there to be a dependence on the
previous M steps okay so that's going to
be the basic way that we deal with some
of these high dimensionality issues and
then I'll talk about how that
probabilistic structure not only can be
used for the full trajectory but we also
can look at trajectory fragments as the
signatures that we use in the
discriminator to drive the generator
towards the data distribution samples so
the key idea here is really we want to
we want to be completely sample based so
we can avoid having to specify
likelihood functions so throughout there
will be no likelihood functions so you
can think about these as being methods
that are alternatives to maximum
likelihood estimation all right so learn
representations I'm going to use as my
model class stochastic m-step methods so
just to get some notation uh specified
uh this is just saying that outing this
um probabilistic graphical structure I'm
showing here on the right will have that
state J depends on the previous M States
you can think of PSI J minus 1 as the
update from time step or step J minus 1
to J
Omega J here will be the sample point
because we're dealing with the
stochastic process and then the P here
will be whatever parameters we have of
the system so these could be your
weights of neural networks or they could
be uh parameters of the physical system
that you'd like to learn from your
trajectory observations I'll also allow
the parameters to influence the the
initial conditions or you could think
about that as coming from some Ensemble
for the the initial conditions of the
system all right so that's the basic
setup in the model class that we're
going to use for our implicit generators
and this provides all kinds of ways to
incorporate prior knowledge physical
principles we can sort of design into
this update all kinds of features I'm
going to replace the standard um kind of
Jensen Shannon Divergence approach of
the original Gans formulation with
another approach that's kernel based and
that will also provide some other ways
to incorporate inductive biases um and
then as I said before this encodes
essentially these probabilistic
dependencies so we're not learning over
the general space of you know r n times
D random variables we're really learning
over this class of uh graphical models
now once you do that there's also a way
to introduce different training
protocols realize you can train this
quite effectively not just using the
full trajectory data but also using
things like additional distributions or
even just marginal distributions and
this allows for potentially big
reductions in the number of Dimensions
you have to deal with during the
training process because you can utilize
trajectory fragments and so I'll show
some results there as well as down
sampling by using different time skills
Tau so the overall objective then is
going to be to develop appropriate
discriminators and critics for this sort
of dynamic scenario currently what we're
developing are methods within the
context of generalized moment methods or
maximum mean discrepancy and and we
found in practice this seems to lead to
some nice results with respect to
avoiding some of those oscillations like
I showed you in the standard Gans
formulation all right so those three
training protocols I'll just say a
little bit about them briefly because
they'll kind of come back when I develop
some of the algorithms so in the full
trajectory case essentially what we're
going to think of as the implicit
generators distribution
would just be essentially the sequence
of snapshots of the dynamic trajectory
and of course that's going to be very
high dimensional and that's not very
desirable in training because
um you know again getting sample
coverage in a high dimensional space is
uh is quite challenging so you need
rather large batches to get meaningful
uh comparisons so what we're going to do
often is down select in two different
ways a delta T here that I'm mentioning
doesn't necessarily have to be the time
step of the m-step generator this could
be much larger time steps so that you're
only sampling at you know select times
and that way you can get sensitivity to
the dynamic responses on large time
scales but the underlying numerics is
using a much uh smaller sub step and so
that's the strategy we'll typically use
with these full trajectory approaches
and that's what's being denoted here by
this Tau that you're seeing there uh and
so the conditional methods as the name
implies this will be where we'll use uh
trajectory fragments this would be most
of appropriate where we're able to
generate entries of the training set
from something like a high fidelity
simulation so these would start off with
like the same local initial conditions
and then evolve for some period of time
it's kind of like a little local burst
if you like of trajectories and then of
course you're learning these probability
distributions which are conditionals on
those different samples for the initial
conditions and that that that has
obviously training benefits again if you
have some control over initializing the
the training debt set data and then the
marginals don't require that the
marginals simply just take a fragment of
the trajectories and essentially you're
just trying to learn marginal
distributions for some specified ranges
you can either do it as kind of like a
sliding window or you could have it at
one specific time so the main point I
really want to make is there's all kinds
of interesting variations and
combinations of what I've specified here
that can be used to greatly improve
potentially training when you're trying
to learn these dynamical models and so
I'll focus on these kind of three
standard cases all right so for the
generator loss I'm going to reformulate
it so I'm not simply using a zero one
classifier and this is with the
objective of trying to get a little bit
more information about the dynamical
trajectories that can be used as a
learning signal in the gradient of the
generator and so what I'm going to do is
instead of using just a sort of binary
classifier I'm instead going to learn a
critic or a discriminator that is
essentially a function which is going to
aim to distinguish between the two
probability distributions so you can
think about this function as basically
being like a signature that tells me how
different these two random variables are
where the function is restricted to come
from some range of features or
functional forms and I'll get into that
in more detailed from the probability in
statistics literature this is what's
known as the integral probability metric
depending how you choose this uh model
class fancy F here you can get all kinds
of interesting metrics including the
cantarovics metric associated with
optimal transport like the Veloster
steam metric for example that would be
the one Lipschitz functions for which
it's constant less than or equal to one
you can make other choices to get other
well-known
metrics and divergences the choice that
we're going to make here and again the
whole purpose of this is to compare the
empirical distribution of the generator
and the training set we're going to use
a reproducing kernel filbert space for f
for f here and we'll look at all of the
functions that have uh Norm in that
space less than or equal to one so
there's a number of nice things that
happen if we use that depending on our
choice of Kernel this of course can give
us rather Rich ability to distinguish
between
probability distributions while at the
same time having some other structure
which we can utilize for the purposes of
training from these finite sample sets a
lot of what will happen here is it'll be
Sim similar to doing something like a
kernel density estimate of the two
distributions and kind of comparing
their difference but of course what
kernel you choose will affect what's
being emphasized in those comparisons so
the key property that I'm going to use
for that kernel for now I'll just leave
the kernel generic and I'll say a little
bit more about what we use when I get
into the examples is we'll use the fact
that if we're in a reproducing Colonel
Hilbert space then we can evaluate the
function f at a particular value X by
simply taking the inner product of f
with the kernel Now using that property
if I substitute that in above here it
actually can be I can simplify the form
of this optimization problem that I need
to solve I'll use the notation mu P you
can think about this as an embedding of
the first probability distribution and
muq as an embedding of the second
probability distribution into the
reproducing kernel Hilbert space I can
use that along with this kernel property
to basically commute the the inner
product with the expectation and if I do
that then this integral probability
metric that I get can be expressed in
this form this is what's known as
maximum mean discrepancy and you can see
readily now that optimizing over all
Norm 1 functions would be given by
simply taking the direction of that
second vector or that second function
and that's simply given by the
difference between the embeddings over
the norm of the embeddings and so when
you work it all out you know again going
back and using this property of kernels
you can express this as the sum of
Kernel expectations now all that looks
great the one drawback of course of this
is that these are second order
statistics and we'll talk about how
we'll deal with that in a little bit and
so this provides us then uh from the
sample based point of view this would
provide us with a loss function for our
generator in particular
we can take this expectation quantity
let's just Square it to get rid of the
square root since at the end of the day
we're interested in doing optimization
minimizing and then we can use this
unbiased estimator here which would then
give us a sample based estimate of the
nmd and so that's what we're going to
use for our generator loss this is
basically a way of determining the
discriminator analytically so I don't
have to go through a separate training
or optimization problem like I did in
the standard Gans formulation and so now
that takes the discriminator
optimization part out of the problem and
now I can focus on simply minimizing or
minimizing the objective for the the
implicit generator and so that'll boil
down to this loss function which I'm
showing here which will amount to
essentially the uh the the empirical
estimator for the MMD that I'm showing
in the upper right and this is uh just
Computing nmd the unbiased estimator for
effectively those empirical
distributions of G and D all right so
that's going to be the overall loss that
I'm going to use in my generative
formulation and now it boils down to how
do I actually compute the this in
practice for performing training using
things like stochastic gradient descent
and so what's really crucial here is
that I'd be able to compute gradients of
that loss function efficiently and it
turns out that if I use just standard
back propagation methods of the
computational column graphs it should
become prohibitively large for backpro
so I'm going to you make use of more a
mathematical structure of this loss
function and so the first observation is
just to note that we have to do these
double sums over the samples not very
computationally efficient again if we
were to use a sort of direct back prop
on the computed Expressions but we have
a lot of probabilistic dependence here
that we know in advance we know that the
sample points for example come from
those m-step updates we know a lot about
the the structure of the objective
function coming from the the kernel
evaluations that I showed you before and
so uh you know again High Dimensions
having to deal with the second order
statistics and that's what I'm going to
address next so the basic approach that
we're going to take is closely related
to adjoint methods and we're going to
use that died in a judicious way both
for computing aspects of the second
order statistics as well as the
dependence on the stochastic
trajectories and in this way then we'll
have a viable training protocol for
learning over those m-step methods with
these MMD lawsuits uh so just to give a
quick overview of those techniques what
we're doing is we're ultimately trying
to compute gradients of an expectation
and so the way that we'll look at this
from a mathematical perspective is we'll
build all of the dependencies into the
parameters P that we're trying to learn
into the random variable so we'll assume
there's some base measure I call that
Omega you can view then the expectation
in our case it's the MMD that we're
taking expectations of the stochastic
trajectories are being generated by an
implicit generator that has some
parameters P so the random variable is
what has the P dependence not the base
measure and in that case then we can
commute taking gradients in the expected
quantity with taking expectations of the
grade of the random variable essentially
right so that's just the key assumption
that we're going to make in our notation
essentially our formulation and of
course what we're doing here is a
discrete approximation of that
expectation and it follows as I've shown
here on the right to effectively being
able to compute gradients of the sample
terms okay so now if you look at the
gradients of the sample terms the
problematic part is having to create
gradients in the stochastic trajectory
components and if you were to go through
again and kind of do this in a
straightforward way using the chain rule
this becomes rather expensive because
you would compute gradients in all the
different stochastic trajectories and
then ultimately contract them with these
partials X and Phi and so it turns out
and this is an Insight that's used in
adjoint approaches and control theory
and other areas it turns out that
because you're doing this contraction
there's actually an alternative
formulation of the contribution of this
term and I'll walk you through how that
plays out in the context of um of our
methods so the challenge is to compute
efficiently the contributions of those
gradients in P of the sample set so as
you adjust the parameters of the
stochastic model right that's going to
affect all of the the samples that are
produced and that's what we need to deal
with so the alternative approach that
we're going to take is going to be based
on an adjoint formulation and really
what we're going to utilize is the fact
that if you look at the solution to that
m-step method you see that it solves
this implicit equation here and so where
F has these components and if we do that
this implicit formulation allows us to
utilize the implicit function theorem
which basically says that if we take a
derivative in the parameters we can
express it in this way using the total
derivative and we can actually solve for
XP in terms of derivatives of f so we've
kind of shifted everything off to the
implicit function f instead of having to
compute in terms of XP directly and that
has a bunch of nice properties as you'll
see because now what I can do is I can
can contract this expression quite
readily and often I'll get a problem
that's much easier to solve than if I
had constructed all of those explicit
gradients all right so then XP can be
expressed in terms of the Jacobian in
this way in terms of derivatives of the
implicit function f all right so I've
just copied that over here on the left
and the adjoint approach is to compute
then the full derivative by plugging in
this expression for XP and then just
rearranging the order in which you're
going to do the contractions and if you
do that then you can show that this
whole expression would boil down to
essentially Contracting a vector r with
FP where R satisfies this equation so
the real challenge then I would say is
they come up with a deficient way to
compute each of the steps in this
gradient computation which is to compute
g x f x that gets you the Jacobian have
an efficient solver for R then compute
gpfp and then now you get your full
gradient through combining those terms
with that solution arm it's really the
computation of R that's typically uh the
part that um that could get
computationally expensive I'll show you
in the context of these m-step methods
we actually can get very efficient
algorithms in fact a solver which
amounts to solving a system of
recurrence equations to construct that
Vector all right so that's the objective
and in all that will be used to compute
the gradients of these empirical
estimators of the expectation all right
so just to get through that the second
order statistics I don't want to say too
much about that you can basically use
the chain Rule and again if you
judiciously look at what you get it
turns out that you can reduce things to
essentially doing an adjoint method on
this linear function I won't say very
much about it but you can use the
technique that I've showed you on the
previous slide to construct then
derivatives of the overarching loss so
the real challenge then comes up to
having effective adjoint methods for the
stochastic trajectories and so I'll
focus on that just in the interest of
time and so up there on the upper left
is the gradient method this is the
implicit formulation including the
initial conditions I'll go through this
rather quick because I do want to have
sufficient time to talk about results
you can look in our paper for a lot of
the details but just some notation fjd
will be the the implicit equation for
the jth step and D component and then
when I take a derivative I'll just put
that second index uh there so putting
all these pieces together what you
basically have to compute is for these
implicit equations you have to compute
the following Jacobian that's done
rather straightforwardly using these
fjdfk D Prime terms and you take the
transpose this gives you a set of linear
systems I'm going to break the r Vector
down into components corresponding to
this steps at the end of the trajectory
all the way back to the beginning so
what I'm really utilizing here is that
probabilistic dependency that I have in
particular the form of these updates and
so if I do that I can first compute RN
then use that to compute RN minus 1 all
the way down to r0 put all those
together composite that will get me R
and I can use that in my gradient
calculation to get the update so that's
the strategy here I realize I'm going a
little quick but I just in the interest
of time want to go through this um
briefly and I'll refer you to the paper
for for a more in-depth discussion so at
the end step you basically have this
particular equation for the RN
components you can solve that outright
in terms of derivatives of feet uh now
you have that if you go to step n minus
1 and minus two and so on back you can
again solve directly for our KD you put
everything here on the right hand side
notice those indexes are plus one plus l
so you have those in hand from the
previous step and then of course if
you're more than M steps away from the
end point then you get this generic
formula that again allows you to solve
for RK in terms of the previous iterates
that you already have in hand so this
gives you a very efficient solver now to
get R and that's sort of the key
component in our gradient calculations
for doing stochastic grade Descent of
this uh this generative modeling
approach all right I'll refer you to the
papers again for details there and I've
already said a lot about the training
protocols and and these can be obviously
adapted and applied quite readily within
each of these uh contexts all right so
let me in the remaining time just talk a
bit about some of our early results with
these methods as I mentioned it's pretty
recent and ongoing work so the first
problem I mentioned was learning uh
parameters of mechanical systems and in
particular I'm going to look over uh the
model class of longevon Dynamics these
will be inertial Ornstein woolenback
processes so you can think about that
bead spring system and the objective
here is from observations of the
trajectories essentially to learn the
stiffness of damping and the fluctuation
related terms and I'd like to do that
simultaneously using this generative
approach the challenge of course with
that is dimensionality these are
basically what the observables are I
don't have a lot of time to go into
detail here but you can see that there
are different time skills at which those
different parameters are sensitive and
that does play a role in how you
ultimately formulate those those
training protocols that I was referring
to and I'll refer to the paper again for
some more in-depth discussion of that
and be happy to talk offline so I just
want to point that out qualitatively you
see that the way that'll manifest is
when we're observing and doing our
training if we use for example the
conditionals and the the marginal
distributions we're essentially training
over observations that are analogous to
what I'm showing here on the right all
this is done for a three-dimensional
system we're using a rational quadratic
kernels I should mention and there's an
important role that this time scale Tau
that we sub-sample on plays in the
training protocols so here's some
quantitative results I'll just start
with the stiffness you can see as we
vary Tau we're able to get this quite
accurately estimated we we estimated
stiffness temperature damping
simultaneously something interesting
happens in the training in that just
like with maximum likelihood estimation
there's a tendency to get pulled towards
a local minimizer where if you make the
temperature very large of course that
will make the training data quite
plausible under your model but in a
sub-optimal sense one of the nice things
about the MMD that we noticed is that
once the stiffness seems to get within
the right ballpark it gets pulled away
from that kind of local
minimizer towards then the correct
temperatures you're seeing here in this
particular training run and similarly
with the with the damping so you can see
that there's also interesting
sensitivity on the time scales here and
just comparing the different protocols
full conditional marginals for a
relatively large sampling time scale
versus a small sampling time scale you
can see that that plays significant role
in the accuracy of the results
especially when we look at something
like the conditionals we get very good
accuracy for large time scales because
there's sufficient sensitivity to
stiffness whereas as we go to very small
time scales essentially that learning
signal that you would get for
determining the stiffness parameter is
getting washed out by other things like
the thermal fluctuations and the damping
so so these are important hyper
parameters to keep in mind when training
on these stochastic systems this just
shows we get a very accurate result for
stiffness we similarly did a study with
temperature this is all all the
parameters are changed trying
simultaneously we're finding
temperatures are much more challenging
for them to pin down in detail partly
because it can make up some of the
discrepancy between the models by simply
increasing the noise so if we don't have
perfect overlap between the training
samples and the generated samples it can
kind of make those things line up and
agree so it might be picking up simply
on the sampling error and that's
something we're currently investigating
for many trading runs we'll see the
behavior that you're seeing in terms of
epochs here but for some of them they
fail for the reasons that I leave it to
similarly we can estimate the damping
parameter and again you see some
sensitivity there on the time scales at
which the Dynamics are are probed and so
we see in each case different pros and
cons to those different training
protocols but the SD Gans you can mix
and match or choose between those
approaches as well as tuning that time
scale tab this is just showing real
quickly some results for learning uh
models where there's unknown Force laws
and so in this case we have observations
of a particle system and we're going to
learn over the modeling class of again
inertial longevon Dynamics and really
the objective here is to learn neural
network representation for the unknown
Force law uh here I'll assume for now in
this study that the damping and the
thermal uh parameters are known but you
also could try to learn those
simultaneously as well but again you
have that challenge of these very sort
of high dimensional probability spaces
but that graphical model structure will
be utilized to exploit that those
dependencies uh so here on the left is
showing uh the kinds of observations we
have obviously many more than just these
three or four samples but just to show
you what the data sets look like that
we're training from essentially an
ensemble of trajectories of that nature
you'd be learning from observing those
Dynamics on the right is learning over
trajectory fragments we do that with the
conditional and the marginals so this is
just showing some results this is the
case of we're doing a radial symmetric
double well potential this is showing
the force law that targeting we're using
a neural network representation for this
neural network so we're training again
using the back custom back propagation
approaches I showed before and this is
showing the model that we learned and
really I think the advantage of these
approaches is that we're not reliant on
things like the system having
equilibrated which would be required for
for techniques that make use of sort of
a priority knowledge of the marginals we
also can deal with systems that are
potentially not in equilibrium because
the primary driver of the statistics
that we're trying to align are the the
intrinsic longevonne Dynamics and so on
the right is just showing training the
double well potential and then the way
we're going to characterize this is in
terms of the L1 error of the radial
distribution function this is not
something that was used in the training
but just to have reliable test errors
which would govern a lot of the
statistics ultimately of that model that
you've learned and I'll just show some
quick results for that this is just
showing on the left the the Learned
model so you can see that we get viable
long-time simulator years and on the
right is uh is showing um the the
training data set
and uh and then this is just showing
some quantitative results and again we
we did some studies as we varied the uh
the temporal sampling uh parameter so I
won't go into a lot of detail there
which is to show that yeah we're able to
learn non-linear um Force laws and uh
we're kind of pushing this in a number
of directions to uh improve both the
dimensionality and the complexity of the
problems that we can deal with but I
hope this gives kind of a proof of
concept of uh some of the recent work
that we've been doing and I'd be happy
to talk more about that offline I'll
refer you to the papers so thanks again
for having me um look forward to
continuing discussions